today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza in Los
Angeles and bronx-born pizza in Bend
Oregon gray block and bronx-born get him
[Music]
what's up you low arthropods huh what is
an arthropod I think it's a um like a
you know like a deadiy
very daddy longlegs you know like a yeah
like a daddy longlegs it's not a crazy
name for a little um you know a a
cricketer you know insect a daddy
longlegs a daddy longlegs think about
that kind of a pervy name isn't it oh
look at that daddy longlegs huh when you
think about that yeah man welcome to
this past weekend let's get
[Music]
[Music]
broke down out of truck stop she looked
about as wild as the stove is she
says she was a Christian saving souls
and Savannah and the Lord was sending
her to Alabama
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up what's up pup this that is
alabama by bishop gun and you can see me
you know actually you know i'm not i'm
not even humble bragging i'm just
straight telling you that you can see me
in their video they let me be an actor
and their video and actor and an actor
is somebody that impersonates things
that are that's somebody else made up
which is bizarre really but they let me
do it and it was fun man i was out there
just I mean we shot this thing outside
of Nashville and I was out there battle
in the dark hearts boy every time I
turned around there was something
something lecherous and deviant you know
just one of the devils 10th achlys had
just reached out from the depths from
the fiery dusty dirty chocolate
you know starfish sniffin depths of of
existence I mean come up and just try
and just just suck on my tongue you know
that was a crazy that's and that's what
happened there and they would try to
come and get me and just lure me back in
lure me back into the devil's billfold
you know just learn me right back in and
into in the Haiti's butt crack you know
butt crack and that's what it's about
man it's me battle on the dark arts and
Bishop Gunn gave me an opportunity to be
in a video and it was a lot of fun you
know so you can go check that out and
then link will be on our YouTube and
support their song Alabama if you are on
the YouTube I'm in the new we got a new
set we got a new set and man you know
it's funny like it is exciting man they
got we got
people have sent us all kind of stuff we
have a jock a willings book in here
we've got the unruly bastards game we
got ridged wallet it's all wood in the
back and this is you know wood was
recovered from I think a ship or a Navy
ship or something or you know or just
local wood or something four by sixes or
something 60s and they got Jordan
Peterson book a pumpkin right there
when a mother Nick his [ __ ] dirty
little you know gonads right there one
of those orange little party poppers
that she floats out this time of year
and isn't it kind of crazy that think
about this mother nature at this time of
year makes orange vegetables for fun
isn't that amazing isn't that just some
you know what she's just like you know
what I've been doing regular fruits and
vegetables all year it's October
I'm gonna make a couple of these [ __ ]
beautiful
spicy little you know little naranja
Orange knickknacks these round you know
these round little vestibules
and that's amazing that she does it and
she does it every year and she remembers
that that mother nature has that that
she's that acute that's it that
fastening and think about how acute
nature is man just one thing to the next
keep it going you know time to make this
timeless start a waterfall time to up
keep churning the quicksand you know oh
don't forget these birds got to be born
here they go
patch them up time for the orange
vegetables think about think about what
mother nature does and what a powerful
woman that is and the upkeep and she
shows up year after year it's another
thing that's fascinating mother nature
shows up year after year and she's
constantly here for us it's really
pretty beautiful when you think about it
that mother nature is here for us it's
really really beautiful and the rest of
this you can see I got my nieces and
nephews up there I've got five nieces
and nephews their names are JC Renee
Zephie Stella max and Madison and I got
a picture of them up there and we got
everything a lot of gifts people have
brought us George Carlin we got that
warm rod that showed up last week we got
that Noah syndergaard that autographed
ball in here what else we got the HAMP
that my boy gave me over there and
outside of Nashville we got that great
block pizza advertising right there we
got these Piedmont candles we got a lot
of nice things that have come in here
and so I'm just letting you know from
time to time things will change on the
on the shelf behind me and
don't get upset if you sent something
and it's there and then it's not it's
just the way life is things change you
know you know sometimes mother nature
makes one's vegetables and then
sometimes she doesn't and that's okay
you know that's okay things change oh
what's going on with me this week I
didn't do that much you know I was
really excited our producer Nick you
know showed up yesterday and got this
got this bad boy installed we are what
else is going on you know I was feeling
honestly like a little bit down in the
daisies last week and so I'm trying to
climb out of that you know I've been
really struggling with smoking
cigarettes to be honest with you and
every time I do that they take me away
from you know I don't enjoy it so they
take me away from happiness every time I
do it I'm just feeling bad about myself
so it's not even something that I enjoy
anymore you know so I you know it'll be
okay I just got a you know I don't like
that they make me feel just downtrodden
that's what they make me feel like what
else is happening you know everybody's
talking about the movie a star is born I
want to go see that oh not too much else
but I'm so excited to have this new
studio and I and I have on her nice
shirt and you'll see that if you are
able to see this on the YouTube you can
see I have on a really I mean this is
custom knit this is knitted or you know
expertly done or something like that I
got this shirt and a shirt is a place
where your body can hide you know
because at some point in time you know
people said hey we're tired of looking
at your tits or your chest or your back
or your navel I bet that's what a lot of
it was because you know people's navels
brough they don't take care of they may
VLEs your navel start stinking bro
then you know that I used to date a girl
and she had I mean she had I'll say this
she was beautiful lady okay she had
beautiful nice head nice um arms
you know torso nice you know her
skeleton you couldn't see her skeleton
but it'll seem like it was nice because
of the you know the accoutrement that
were on it the muscle and tendons and
skin but she had a I mean her navel
smelled like somebody had just been
hiding just little just little pieces of
olives in there
I mean her navel just I mean it smelled
like somebody had just been just been
making just dirty cotton candy down in
there you know cotton candy that didn't
have any cotton in it
and it just had candy and just uh you
know different you know just different
types of booty sense and her navel man I
couldn't so it was just crazy like
instead of like if we were making out or
being you know getting if she and I were
being you know making out are getting
kind of you know essentially authentic I
would try to cover her navel up with one
hand and so it's hard to really you know
it's hard to you know you know maneuver
well on a woman's body when you just got
one you know it's got one hand and I and
I'm right-handed so I would cover her
navel up with my right hand so that
means I'm feeling around her body and
touching her and trying to you know do
romance type of touch with my left hand
which is not my this is my secondary
hand you know I only only shake hands
with my left hand if say if I've been in
a fire or if you know my right hand is
stuck in a you know in a car door or
something like that that's the only time
I would ever shake hands in my left hand
or you know if somebody else is already
shaking my right hand and I want to keep
shaking hands at the same time because I
you know I want to you know cut corners
and I don't want to you know I don't
want to you know I want to be efficient
then I would that's the only time I
shake hands on my left hand but but so
when I'm when I remember when I was
making out with that girl
I would have to put my you know I could
if that because if that scent hit me out
of that navel
that navel she had that little I mean it
was just a little it was just a cause
you know had caught it was this a little
just Cauldron it was almost like a front
kind of little bootie you know you know
it was like a you know kind of like a
bootie but didn't go very deep and it
just was poorly scented and so I cover
it up with one of my hands and I would
try to feel her body and touch her and
be natural with her and massage her neck
and stuff with my secondary hand my left
hand and and it was hard man you know
I've never been blind or anything like
that but I've had to do that which is
where you cover somebody's navel because
of the stench and you try to touch them
and be natural with your secondary hand
and that is very hard to do it's very
very hard to do it's kind of like you
know that game where they say like you
know touch your head and turn your own
you know spin your hand and put one hand
on your stomach and move it at the same
time that little game they do it's kind
of like that but while you're erect and
wanting to be sensual and that's what's
kind of different about it but but yeah
it's just you know I don't even what I
was talking about oh nope nothing but
yeah it's just that time of year you
know it's that time of year where you
know where you got oh nope but I still
know what I was talking about well I'll
just say this man mother nature is a
real fancy lady she's a real fancy lady
and I love a lot of what she does and so
I'm grateful to be here on uh on her big
ball bag here planet Earth but I what's
been going on man I've been thinking a
lot about the future honestly you know
I've been thinking a lot about the
future and I'm a little bit scared I
don't know if I'm scared but I'm just
like well wonder what the future is
gonna be like like is it gonna keep
getting more automated that you know
that they're not gonna need us like
somebody said the other day they're like
I heard anyway someone say that they
think we've bought our last car
like the car you've bought most recently
will be the
last one that you'll buy that after you
know that in the coming years it'll all
be like shared cars where everybody's
ubering or you know using something you
know like a shared it'll be like a
shared vehicle and I was like wow that's
pretty wild like imagine you know not
having a car anymore
my can go outside of your house and you
just have to stand there because there's
no car just kind of you know is that the
future what the future is gonna be like
and if everybody's gonna keep cooking
food or will it just be like things are
delivered like smoothies I feel like
everybody's just starting to drink
smoothies man dude I had a dream the
other night right for people in my dream
were drinking a smoothie and I've never
had that happen before so what does that
tell you it tells you that something
could be on the loose something could be
happening it's just you know it's crazy
to think what the future will be like if
you know if I start to wonder if like
our senses and stuff like that or just
like are we gonna start to develop I
thought about this well we have like a
new layer of skin that we will wear like
think about like right now we still have
our you know or our regular skin and it
can get cut or something like that and
broken or whatever get a rash but I'm
wondering if in a few years or something
they'll just have like a suit that
you'll wear at all times and it will
keep your body temperature regulated it
will keep you insulated it will keep you
protected so like if a building or
something falls on you you'll be okay
and it'll be at that point it'll be like
people will be like do you remember like
like you remember when people used to
have just their regular skin with no
form of protection and that'll sound
insane if you know somebody that used to
be like that I mean it already sounds
crazy I remember growing up writing we
used to write we write everything and
now that almost sounds crazy to think
crazy to think that oh well remember we
took a stick we heard somebody told us
something and to remember we took a
that had like a wet color coming out of
it and rode it onto a piece of a tree
that we had a piece of paper and that
was how we did it that's that sounds
bizarre right now
so imagine well you know just with a few
I just can't I start to wonder what
it'll be like and I'm curious as to what
some of you guys will think you know
what you guys I think that the future
will be like you know will we even have
flavors anymore or will they just have a
thing where you just remind yourself
like a button you press and it just
reminds your brain what something tastes
like you know will we even have I wonder
if our stomachs will have an outdoor pet
you know patio outside of our bodies
where we will install food and just put
it in its like sustenance to keep going
that the joys that you know of eating
and getting to know each other and all
of that will just seem kind of archaic I
don't know I bet there's gonna be a lot
of communities gonna start up that that
want to preserve a very human way of
life because the direction we're heading
now it's just you know I don't even know
how human things are anymore you know
it's like we don't even like life does
even have some of the same value
sometimes if you look at on some of this
Instagram they have you know these
different sites and stuff where people
are dying or you know or like kids are
doing crate you know stunts
you know like butthole Jonathan or you
know alopecia Jeanette and and then it's
like somebody who you know you'll do
it'll just be a picture of like a kid
jumping off a building on a skateboard
and you're like what the did the kid
died and he'll like hit you know he'll
he'll land on like a teeter-totter or
something break she completely shattered
his legs you're like holy [ __ ]
is that is he okay what hey
you'll see a kid get shot out of a
cannon into a stop sign or something
like six hundred yards away and you're
like wow why you'll see you know two
people will you know will
we'll jump into a volcano we'll do a
backflip into a volcano you're like what
the [ __ ] and it's just like awesome five
stars so lit fire fire fire you're like
oh those people are they dead is that a
lot what is it and it's just like we
don't even it's almost like it doesn't
even damage us anymore if we see that
kind of stuff we're just getting we're
getting far along we're getting down me
we're getting down the rabbit hole of I
feel like that we've done everything
that everything has been exploited
everything has been you know everything
that's he that you know that we even
held sacred as humans sometimes has
gotten you know it's been we're
oversaturated with it so I just wonder
what happens you know do we start to
move away from humanity into more like
mmm
you know electronica or what do we do
what do we do I don't know sorry I don't
know if some of this is dying mundane
thoughts but these are just some things
that I've been thinking about a little
bit you know I've been thinking about
those kind of things what else man I've
been thinking about I've been thinking
about you guys have been thinking about
you know I'm excited I'm headed this
week to uh to Appleton Wisconsin and I
think it's sold out and then I'll be an
Orpheum Theatre in Buffalo New York
those shows are still available November
1st and 2nd and 3rd and then I'm in Salt
Lake City Washington DC Addison Texas
those are all sold out and then uh
December 7th and 8th in Lexington
Kentucky and thank you guys so much for
coming out and supporting me you know
it's kind of crazy I can't even believe
I can't even believe that people are
coming out to the shows you know you do
this job for so long you just uh and
people don't come and so I'm just
grateful to have people to entertain you
know because I really love being able to
entertain people what else man what else
is going on you know a lot of great
calls a lot of great questions
you know what here's the hot line is
always is nine eighty five six six four
nine five zero three last week we had a
young lady who called in from Seattle
saying that she wanted have a little bit
more sex than her fiance and she was
more of that sexy that little purveyor
and she was out you know she was kind of
like that buffet and she wanted you know
she wanted her man to show up and have
different snacks and different pieces
and different you know and just you know
she wanted her man to come through the
lawn twice if you know what I'm saying
but that's not what's going on so we had
we had a response somebody called in
with a suggestion for her for her man
homeward I say I got to make this quick
I'm at work to sneak out I heard this
young lady had a problem with their old
man I wanna get dirty anymore yeah and
get dirty he means do that sex more well
don't tell me goes doc your testosterone
tick and I got on some testosterone man
all I want to do is get the sack oh wow
so he got on that testy and he wants to
get in the sack let's hear more anyways
what what you do and keep doing and I
keep keep making my day go by good at
work and and taking each other so man
you do good we appreciate it
and have a have a great have a great
date thanks man I appreciate that thank
you for saying that yeah sometimes I'm
too hard on myself man I don't know
where I learned that you know I think uh
I don't know why and you know it's funny
because I probably wouldn't treat
anybody the way that I treat myself you
know it's just
Appling sometimes you know I would never
like you know if somebody was having a
tough time or something I would just try
and be supportive of them and instead I
treat myself you know I'll just put
myself through the wringer you know
there's this voice in my head sometimes
it's like you know you got to do more
you're not doing enough you got to do
this and even when I do something
sometimes I can't even feel the joy of
doing it you know I can't even feel the
joy of doing it because there's this
there's like this invisible judge inside
of me that just wants to tell it that
will and that judge man I'm realizing
will tell me that until I could be
laying I could have a you know of a
needle stuck in a mile I'm going into
someone else's body who needs blood I
could be draining myself completely of
blood into somebody else and with the
other hand I could be doing a you know a
a puppet show for some children and I
could be on a stationary bike that's you
know that's that's using like you know
create an electricity to power a you
know maybe a you know a vinegar shop or
something like that or a you know a
coffee place and everybody's inside is
enjoying little cups of coffee or cups
of vinegar I could be doing all that at
one time in my brain would be like man
what the [ __ ] you're not doing anything
you know yeah I don't know what that is
inside of me man I and I know maybe
that's any what you were talking about
this has got me thinking my god I hate
that I I don't know why you know I would
never you know I you know I really am
I'm just hard on myself you know I'm
hard on myself I think some also to men
I'm indecisive you know when you're
indecisive you kind of by not making
decisions you just kind of always stay
in the spacious space I find that you
know if since I don't make decisions for
me I find that I always stay in this
anxious space and it's like you know
it's just like man just make some
decisions and move and go and move
forward you know instead I'll stay in
the sanction space and when I'm in that
anxious space it's easier for the part
of my brain to tell me man you know
doing anything it's like if I had a
little bit more definition sometimes
more definitive than I think I would you
know maybe my brain would back off
because it would show a little bit more
of my prowess as a man you know it'd
show a little bit more of my ability to
Shepherd myself but yeah you say you
gotta go get that testosterone checked
and what that is testosterone is just
that level you know it's how much you
know how much butter you got in your cup
and it's you know testosterone is that
kind of thing makes you perk up
you know it's whenever you hit a see
ever hit a speed bump in your car and
you don't faint or you don't die or
anything like that you don't scream do
you all right that's because
testosterone holds you down you ever
shaken somebody's hand you know with
either hand
yeah they don't they don't snap your arm
off do they no because testosterone
holds you together you know you ever uh
have you ever you ever ripped one of
your nose hairs out just get in there
and just rip one out well that has
nothing to do with testosterone dude
that's crazy though
that's crazy some dudes will do that I
used to have a buddy a mom and he got
see him sometimes he got and I'm worn
outside of work and he got there and rip
a couple out and he yelled his wife's
name too and he would do it you know
Lizzie and he just ripped one damn and
he named all of them Lizzie and he
[ __ ] ripped them things right out of
his snout man he was really really
stressed I think but yeah I don't know
that testosterone you got to get a check
down and maybe that's the thing I mean
you get a little bit of testosterone
I'll go in on something get me a little
testosterone off like a clay bank in the
spring you know I'm saying I'll walk
along the side of a river until I find
you know mother nature's you put that
soft little clay bank out there for me
man I'll get in there you know and some
people don't think about that kind of
stuff
clay is uh it you know clay
safe to have sex with and it's really
almost mother nature saying hey come
over here
don't you practice on the you know
practice on me before you get out there
so very interesting when you think about
what clay is we have some other great
calls that came in we're gonna get to
some of those I'm gonna ask you guys as
well if you want to support the podcast
that you can buy me on DS me undies are
they're great underwear and sometimes
inside of your pants you don't even know
what's in your pants especially if the
day if it's like 4:00 in the afternoon
and you've had a busy day do you who
could anything could be in there you
could be missing a pencil you know you
could be if spit you know spit a little
bit of chocolate sauce in there whatever
well that is uh that that is why you
need me undies see you know what's in
your pants and they are made of micro
motile fabric it's three times softer
than regular cotton regular cotton it's
pretty soft but it's not that soft
sometimes you see regular cotton kind of
whispering and being like jealous and
what they're jealous of is micro motile
fabric me undies releases multiple fun
prints each month it's a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you're gonna love
them and you can get 15% off your first
payer and free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to meet undies
coms last weekend that's me undies
dot-com slash weekend let's take another
couple of calls that came in here we go
onward
hey what cuz POS Brad from Kansas what's
up Brad thank you for calling man hey I
was looking at this past weekend when we
were talking about Halloween and how you
love it
Halloween actually used to be my
favorite holiday man I loved uh being
able to put on a mask and just get away
oh yeah
oh you put that mask on man it's like
yeah and you're just looking out of the
eyeholes and then you just you almost
don't even feel human a little bit you
almost don't even feel like human let's
hear more you know and everyone seems so
happy but my dad actually passed away on
Halloween this will be the second
Halloween with
and I'm just trying to I'm trying to
understand how I just got back you know
how I get that love for how I'm weird
back because you know every time it
comes around I think about my old man
and just what are you doing and where
you know how he did proud of me man
well I'm sorry to hear that man about
your father you know it's uh it's a why
it's a it's a tricky deal I think being
alive because it's not gonna last
forever you know and I think you have a
really unique opportunity I see here you
know your father passed away there on
Halloween and what you could do is you
could dress up like your dad have you
thought about that you know to really
you could be him
and for one night on the 10th you know
for one night of the year take him out
and just you know enjoy the world as if
you're him and I'm not saying go visit
people and surprise people or something
like that or stop by you know I wouldn't
even tell your mother or anything like
that I think this would just be
something for you and him to have
together but if you were to dress up
like your father you know you maybe
could drive by some of his old friends
houses or you know maybe dry or you know
or go buy the school that he used to go
to or something you know take his spirit
for a walk if you will because I think
there's something special about
Halloween you know it's a time you know
the way that that the different chasms
of existence and and in in life and
outer space and mother nature and
Pandora's Box you know in God's bonnets
and all of that the way they all fit
together it's very much like a Rubik's
cubes and a Rubik's cubes is a shape
that doesn't want to show you who it
really is and there's something special
on Halloween when all those when
everything kind of lines up and you can
walk through from the beyond to the
great beyond and to the before and you
can meander back in full
like you're just in a big house party
and time just kind of shows up and just
you know it doesn't keep track of itself
and a full moon comes out and there's
wolves and it's a very very unique time
and it's a very much it's just a
waterslide of just existence and
possibility it's like the universe just
like loses its memory for just a second
and forgets where it's going for just a
second and there's something special
that can happen on Halloween and so
that's how I think it would be very
interesting for you may be dressed up
here as your father and went out and
about now if you wanted to get real fun
with you can stop by hit you know maybe
an ex girlfriend in his house or if he
used to play cards with his buddies you
could set up a game and meet all in him
and do that you know and really live it
out but I think that would be a special
way that you could honor him man but
I'll tell you this no matter what you
choose to do your dad loves you and the
love you know I remember when my father
passed away I was 16 years old my dad
died and man it hurts so much you know I
didn't even know I could hurt like that
you know it felt like that it felt like
if
really felt like God was punishing me
for something you know I remember crying
so much at his funeral in my tears would
they hit the lenola floor and my dad had
another family and they um an older
family and they didn't put us in the
funeral and like the notes or anything
so I remember you know they just were up
there saying that he was survived by you
know only three children or whatever
when he had seven children it was like I
remember they didn't do that you know
they figured they paid for the funeral
or whatever that we did they didn't have
to do that or whoever set it up did and
now dismember feeling like I didn't even
exist like manna Here I am I my father's
funeral and I'm not even you know I
don't exist and I just felt and I
remember my tear who came out onto the
floor and and and I just their some of
them went into the cracks of this floor
and I remember thinking man I want to
just go into the cracks and I just
wanted to you know never come back you
know I just remember just feeling like
that you know just feeling it's so deep
like that because when you're a parent
when you lose a parent and you're young
suddenly you know you go from being
really not shallow but being very you
know you're holding a comfortable amount
of the world and then suddenly you you
just become so deep you become so deep
and there's so many parts of you that
the part of the world that you've been
holding for so long it doesn't fill the
depth that you have now inside of you
and so you that's how you feel empty
because the world you know doesn't fill
up the pain you have so but I
this now I know and I knew it took me a
while but I finally knew that you know
my dad always loved me your dad will
always love you that's all I'm saying
really I don't know why I took us such a
long road to get there but your father's
always gonna love you and and yeah man
and you'll see him again
and I believe that and he and all he
wants for you probably in the meantime
is for you to be comfortable and to be
well and know that he loves you and I'm
just guessing about that but but I bet
it's a okay guess all right thank you so
much for that call and I want to thank
right now we got the new studio and
there was something kind of missing I
was talking with producer Nick and was
something kind of missing and we believe
that it is this this flag right here and
this is an American flag if you're not
sure what country you're in or if you
live in a different country and you
haven't seen it you know in a while this
is the US flag and and it's made by the
legacy flag dot-com and they make these
handcrafted and charred heirloom pieces
right here and this had old stars and
stripes you know that [ __ ] that baby
that Richard Nixon you know this is
Richard Nixon's you know birth blanket
right here this that Bekir awesome baby
get that head are and you could check
out the detail in there you can get a
splinter on this thing man but barely
that's how comfortable and realistic it
is if you smell that thing you could
smell damn you could probably smell Davy
Crockett's breath and so that's
remarkable and you don't get that kind
of crash when the Shepherd you can smell
the breath of an American legend right
there it's probably this feels like
thousands of Paul Bunyan's butt cracks
right there and that's beautiful and
there's not a lot of other opportunists
like that they're out there and this
gonna keep our studio swaggy so you can
go to the legacy flag dot-com and use
the promo code dark arts for free
shipping that's legacy flag dot-com and
the promo code dark arts
alright let's take another call here hey
Dan
therefore hey Dan from Pittsburgh thanks
for calling I will comment I rather
listen to you for a long time now and I
just heard you talk about on the last
podcast Sebastian but back when I was
dabbling in the dark arts myself I kinda
went on a little best buying spree as
well
oh yeah you got them vest huh and I love
a vest man a vest is the only piece of
clothing that you can look sharp and
catch a football at the same time
comfortably name another piece of
clothing you can do that well you could
do socks or just Underpants but normally
just a vest okay
vest you if you can wear a vest if you
don't know if you want to hug somebody
and feel a little bit more of the hug
than usual that's a vest if you don't
know you know you've been drinking all
day or doing drugs whatever you don't
know if you're supposed to go to a
wedding or a rave you're not sure hmm
what am I gonna wear a snorkel no a vest
and this is a snorkel feet a torso baby
that [ __ ] best if you you know if you
if you think about you know you know if
you're not sure if you're gonna do magic
later on tonight vest vest is super
super super popular very rare you know
what I'm saying in the crazy thing about
vests is they remember your body shape
no you know not a lot of different a
piece of clothing remember your body
like a vest does or like a condom you
put on a condom again it remembers the
contours of you so does a vest owed a
vest knows if you're a man or a woman a
vest knows in fact a vet you want to
have a gender-reveal party tie a vest
around your lady's abdomen you know I'm
saying tie a vest up around that womb
unless in look a vest knows a vest knows
a lot more than we
that it does so but yeah let's hear more
I don't have anything crazy but didn't
end up buying like tens s and it's a
great little collection
I still wear em every once in a while
God look dapper but uh yeah just willing
to put that out there thanks to your
love what you do
thank you brother and thanks for buying
vests because more people should buy
them probably one of the top 60 or 70
pieces of clothing I think let's take
another call here we go see oh I got a
problem with you bud mm-hmm
love the show and I love you but uh when
I was listening to the episode with
Sebastian you were saying that you were
afraid to make commitments in your
relationships with whether it be a
girlfriend or maybe friends I don't know
but why man what are you afraid of um
you know you're a good-looking dude
you're funny you're compassionate you
can tell that you care about other
people so walking you and have it be
just okay and normal you know I don't
know it's a good question you know I
don't know why I have such trouble
the trouble with me so it's in the
commitment man it's in the
you know it's just I don't know it's so
hard for me to like just to drop that
anchor you know I think part of me is
worried you know like I you know I don't
want the story to be over you know my
whole life I've you know I've been a
story person I've loved stories I've
loved listening to stories and hearing
stories you know I didn't like my
childhood and so you know I made up
stories you know I didn't get all I
didn't like the bus you know I was
scared to take the bus that I took to
school because kids would see me get off
of it and they would know I was poor you
know because the bus I was on it came
from the poor white and the poor black
neighborhood and so I was scared you
know now I guess I was ashamed and so I
would ride my bike to school and it was
like four or five miles and this was in
fifth grade you know it was really when
I think of it was just crazy just crazy
riding my bike that far to school at
that age fifth grade think about that
and just got out of shame you know I was
ashamed that if people saw me that they
would think oh they would think that you
know oh he's not you know he is he
doesn't have any worth you know and I
guess I already felt so low about myself
that I needed to like feet I needed to
hold on anything that I could but anyway
I say that just because so when it comes
to commitment I you know I always I you
know if I commit or if I set you know I
guess if I I think part of me is if I
settle down then this took my story's
over
the only thing I've ever been able to
control about myself was you know I get
I don't know if I I don't know if it's
what people thought of me but I guess
you know in my that was a disillusion
that I had or something as a child that
you know I could control like I can
control my story you know like I
couldn't control my life I couldn't
control the realities of my life so I
didn't you know what so when it came to
when it comes to commitment it's like if
you commit and then it's like you know
the story that's the problem I can
always tell the story if I don't know if
I stay if I stay uncommitted then this
you know there's still room for us for
for me to to tell my story I guess or to
adjust my story and and and if I stay
uncommitted then then there's no you
know no one can nail me down to my story
and I think when I was young I was just
probably so ashamed now I didn't want
anybody to know my story I didn't want
anybody to know the truths of my life
you know I didn't even want anybody to
know and so you know so I would you know
I'd make up where we lived or I make up
you know I'd say I wrote a different bus
or I would you know I remember I used to
take a bus to a different neighborhood
and get off there and then walk to my
walk to my neighborhood you know I just
didn't I didn't want my truth to be I
didn't want my read my reality to be my
story and so I think I just got
somewhere in there I lost you know I
just didn't commit to the realities of
own life and I think some of that has
kind of made its way into even when it
comes to relationships it's like I'd
rather just
you know I'm afraid if I you know that
if I yeah I guess if I lock myself down
into a future that that I won't be okay
so something in there you know I just
I'm not I'm afraid to lock myself into a
reality because the experience I had I
guess of my previous reality you know of
my reality of growing up and stuff like
that I just didn't it was so
uncomfortable for me you know and I'm
not trying to complain I'm not
complaining
but I am trying to I guess figure out
you know why I think and feel the way
that I do
but anyway man I appreciate the support
you know and maybe I won't be so hard on
myself in the future maybe I will you
know be more hopeful to try and commit
because staying and staying in the
middle and just being like in the middle
of every and just uncut at a certain
point it just is exhausting you know not
making choices and real Stern choices at
a certain point it's just kind of
exhausting and that's where I'm at
sometimes but I think with the
relationship the commitment and being a
lot you know and being having my story
not be malleable I think that's what it
is it's just I don't want to be locked
into any truth
like any real you know just scared and
being locked in locked into something I
guess I don't know this is a great
question and I appreciate you asking it
and help me think about it um what else
do we have man let's take another call
here here we go
hi my name is Greta and um I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are about
hugging versus kissing of greeting like
when you're meeting some runner when you
run into someone I'm not really a big
fan of of either of those options but
people have definitely made comments
about the fact that I'm I'm a little
hesitant to hug them you know if it's
someone like Alice it's not really a
problem but a hug just seems so intimate
you know like you just seem kind of
weird like pressing your body up against
someone you're not really familiar with
but I guess it seems weird I think it
seems weird out here where I live in Los
Angeles I don't know where you live
young lady and look and I appreciate
that you know I'm happy you call it and
make me think about this
hugging versus kissing because the kiss
is just your it's just your lips hugging
that's all it is and then sometimes they
wrestle and try to you know do sex with
each other just with the tongues only
and that's all it is man a tongue is
just a little dick that's in your mouth
a lot of people don't think about that
and the unique part about your question
is is that is that I think in some
places hugging is a lot more normal you
know where I'm from in a rural area I
would hug if somebody introduced me to a
woman a lot of times I would hug them
you know and if they were an adult woman
I'd kiss him on the cheek you know one
cheek I don't get all French and you
know come around the other side of their
head and [ __ ] like that like a damn you
know creep and Tom I'll do one kiss BAM
you know like that you know just like
that [ __ ] you know like a dangerous
Falcon with a
with a cheek fetish I just do that one
peck peck but some you know some people
who do that double sided and that's the
French bro cuz they're always up to some
[ __ ] but the truth is is that if I
hug I go be in both arms you know cuz a
hug is just wrestling somebody real fast
but also not even really you know trying
to hurt each other and I'll poke my butt
out when I do it I don't go naval a
naval now that's when [ __ ] gets damn
Randy right there
when you press flush up against somebody
else's naval during a hug I mean that is
something you rate you know that's
something you see like when children hug
who were hugging for the first time you
know people that have all you know the
Tisza more the mentally deranged they'll
hug sometimes just straight up just
firing it up you know they had a couple
families boss you know how to buddy
growing up his boy named Arry and had a
you know another family down the street
and both of them had children that were
mentally unwell you know some oh you
know and they've you know they were just
kind of living freelance you know when
it comes to some of their genetics and
they would all sometimes they would let
those kids hang out together and spend
time together and beautiful beautiful
and those kids would press their
crotches against each other
I mean violently almost watching like
two bucks or something on the nature
Channel just being real aggressive you
know another time that I think it's okay
to hug somebody navel the navel as if
you guys are twins now if you're twins
you guys are you know you're really
supposed to be one person so the fact
that you guys are hug and aggressively
that's not even crazy you're supposed to
be one person I don't care if you're
having sex together really because if
you think about it you're supposed to
almost be you're pretty much supposed to
be together but and if you guys do naval
the naval or women do navel to navel and
you're twins
it really makes more sense because
you're navels are really you know it's
like two people sharing you know double
straws out of the same you know
you know vanilla shake but I will often
and here in Los Angeles I won't hug a
woman as much you know you got to trust
your instincts out here you know out
here it's a lot more there's a lot more
nerves in the air you know people are
looking you know there's a lot more I
think uncertainty and fear out here
they've created a lot of fear in here
we're out here where it's scary to hug a
man out here or to hug a woman out here
either one and so I'll definitely
usually wouldn't kiss on the cheek out
here unless you know you just trust your
instincts you just trust your instincts
and most of the time if you're well
calibrated your instincts will lead you
correctly I find that let's see it let's
hit another call right here here we go
hey Theo this is uh Richie from sailors
day I love the podcast of love where
you're doing the more you learn about
yourself right the more I learned about
myself you know things I never thought
of that
oh thanks Richie you know I feel like I
was better at that when the podcast
started I've been struggling myself with
uh you know just feeling overwhelmed and
a lot of traveling and just you know
just being kind of retired out a little
bit and so it's hard for me to not even
get in touch with myself recently and
honestly that's been a little bit scary
honestly personally let's hear more but
uh something I haven't thinking about
lately is a jealousy I feel myself just
kind of getting jealous of friends of
mine and just kind of people around me
I'm just kind of curious if that's
something you had TAS held or something
that you still feel and how you deal
with it so I'm kind of struggling with
it all right Thank You Man
love you love you too but thanks for
that I appreciate that is nice you to
say that at the end you know you could
have let it gone out and just go on out
there but you said love you at the end
and I appreciate that you know it's
important it's important sometimes when
you feel that urge man it and I'm saying
this but you choose it often with family
would you feel that urge to say it you
do it you know earlier today I stopped
at a buddy Monza birthday party and I
and you know I hadn't seen a buddy and I
gave him a [ __ ] big
man you know I'll go straight up naval
the naval let our stinks touch it let
you know if my naval stinking your naval
stinking you know if you're a bird I'm a
bird you know so I'll let our Naples
just just get down there and just touch
stinks you know just touch those front
of front stink holes you know and and I
hugged a man something you got it
sometimes you gotta [ __ ] hug somebody
you know even warriors hug each other
you know after these men fight and [ __ ]
they hug each other they shake hands or
they do like a fast hug
so someone that's normal
jealousy is wild you know I think it's
funny man we and especially growing up
you know I was very very jealous I was
very jealous and all well one of the
reasons I was jealous well I mean it
because if you grow up you know my mom
had to work all the time to make money
so that we could you know have our needs
met
you know our basic needs met and so as a
kid you just see like man you know money
is so important that it keeps my mother
away from me you know and it makes you
then in your head it gets stuck that
that's important you know and so then
you see that other people that have
money it makes you jealous of them
because that's the thing that they
really get that you do that you don't
have they get the free time they get the
extra time you know they get to play
sports and do stuff where their mom can
come and pick them up or they get to go
do this and have extra time with you
know afternoons to go camping with their
dad and all that kind of stuff
and so that's real like man you know
that's where a lot of the jealousy would
come in for me especially growing up and
also man when I was young jealousy gave
me something to be you know I didn't
have an identity sometimes you know I
was filled with just so much like
because nobody taught me like if you
have like a figure around it teaches you
hey don't be jealous of them you know
you love you look love others and learn
to lift them up no matter what then I
would then I would have more that built
into me but if nobody tells you that
then you know jealousy is this a it's a
it's an E
easy low-hanging fruit and you're buying
your brain will take those things many
and it gives you something to feel do
when you when you grow up and you have a
chip on your shoulder you grew up in a
rural area don't have much or something
and I don't care what color you are I
was thinking about this here today I
don't care if you're black white Latino
when I really think about those things I
don't know how much I identified as that
as much as I identify more is the color
of the feelings under that person's skin
you know my friend you know one of my
good friends growing up was his kid
Devin and he was black I mean the thing
that we have a thing that we felt a lot
you know I just knew that we were the
same a lot you know and I was a little
bit you know I was more fortunate I
think because you know he went to he
went to jail for murder and I was more
fortunate because I had just a little
more you know I had someone else in my
neighborhood who took me in and helped
me out more something like that you
notice the little extra influence here
there but I identified with him because
it was the colors that were under our
skin whatever those were that made me
really you know made me really I think
connect and that still make me connect
to others those feelings you know that's
more of my connection our own connection
I think sometimes with people but yeah
jealousy is powerful and jealousy is
that thing where you know it gives you
something to be when you don't know who
you are you don't have an identity bruh
jealousy fits perfectly it gives you
something makes you motivated makes you
active you know jealousy [ __ ] Chuck
yeah
jealousy bruh it's powerful man it's
powerful and it's helpful until it's not
powerful and helpful you know and that's
when minoo I mean everything works until
it doesn't work anymore and that's when
you got to get you know you got to
change your patterns what else man let's
take another call thank you so much for
that call man you guys make me think
about a lot of interesting stuff today
I'm
I'm kind of tired I feel bad about
saying that but I just am kind of tired
so I'm gonna be honest with you homework
hey lumpy oh and Nick misses stood from
Oregon I was listening to the Aubrey
Marcus podcast the thousand poundage of
man episode and has just struck me with
a little thought that I thought kind of
could relate to you and myself as well
you know sometimes we get these urges to
you know form a little self-love oh yeah
you took my spraying out busting
yourself out you know busting your nuts
out of your own body with your hand you
know jailbreaking yourself more it may
feel like we have some kind of
addictions you know doing that and these
guys were talking in a way that that
made me think you know maybe that's just
our body telling us you know like hey
I'm you know I'm not crazy masturbation
right now what I'm praising is sex
instead of you know reaching down your
pants and giving myself some love what I
could be doing what we could be doing
it's something to improve ourselves make
ourselves a better person so that we can
connect with another human in a way that
will you know give us gratifying and
fulfilling sex which is what our body
really crazy amen brother
and I think that that used to be you
know I think as crazy as it is it's like
our sexuality know the sexual desires
are almost becoming like an appendix you
know because your appendix used to be
helpful in your body your appendix
that's where your body stored extra
semen I guess if it wanted to or you
know maybe a couple walnuts or something
if he's going for a hike your body might
store a cup of walnuts and your appendix
or you know some glitter some if you're
going to a rave or something or you look
back a Coke or something but now it's
like it we our body doesn't need it
anymore so our body's not doing that
because we're not doing hiking anymore
it's like it though as we start to not
do stuff then our bodies are gonna not
gonna need those things and this will
take a long time to take effect yeah
in nature but nurture wise it won't you
know it's like if if your kids grow up
and they know that mom and dad go to
separate rooms and watch you know or use
different types of you know pleasurable
zhh
and watch visuals that get them to you
know achieve a jackal action then what
then that's what they're gonna think
connectivity is and sexuality is and
yeah it's like when the the ping that
paying that happens in your in your
crotch you know in that in your little
in that nudie nudie valley of yours
between your legs that right down
between your legs but uh that is um when
you get that paying that's a desire and
we've become so I say we I'm so uh you
know like kind of you know unfortunately
programmed poorly where I go going out
when I get my opinion I go straight for
that Ricci you know I go Ricci and I
teach that spilly spilly out of my
wiener and that's not good for you
because that ping is supposed to be a
desire for you to be able to man up
right to do something go learn a trade
learn how to do drywall learn how to run
a hot air balloon
okay learn how to cut hair and but also
you know to be straight or I guess you
could be gay to this doesn't matter that
paying is that ping ping it was that it
was that little alarm that reminded you
oh you should learn a trade because a
trade will attract someone of the
opposite sex and you'll be able to have
sex but now as soon as we get that ping
in our crotch you crack open your phone
you get a little bit of that cellular
you know that but pleasure or whatever
they're doing on there you know playing
you know uh you know they got Foo
Fighters and people you know touching
each other's [ __ ] or something and
then next thing you know you're empty
and that's your whole experience you
haven't you haven't built yourself up at
all if
you've just kind of defeated yourself a
little bit and that's how I see right
you get the ping man the pings you you
save up all your pings and then when you
saw a woman she could see oh wow this
man you can feel his Chi that's what
they call the Chi and that's what the
Chinese called the Chi boy makes you a
next stand up straight
never we got these soft bosses now all
the time running around now I ain't even
got enough nut in my body to hold my
neck up you know you got do don't you
know I got to be honest I Allison and a
neck brace just to [ __ ] go on a date
cuz I ain't got enough chisholm you know
I don't have enough of that super you
know the super baby body glue inside of
me to hold my neck up
that's sad bruh
sad in the future people gonna be
walking you know gonna have a crutch
under their chin holding her neck up
while they stand there and look at each
other because they don't have enough
ping enough nutnut built up inside of
them and and that is one of the things
that I said that's why I'm against
pornography and now if you're still
using it you just party out every now
and then that's fine but if you're going
to it night after night after night and
it you become that pavlov's you know
that's Pavlov's dick you know what I'm
saying the second you hear that whistle
or the second you get that ping in your
Siraj the thing goes up to your brain
and instead of saying okay you need to
go do something to learn something to
attract a woman you know learn to do
bowling learn to you know make a you
know uh a gumbo or uh you know make a
fancy chicken meal or make a pot pie or
something you know make that you know
them green beans bread something right
there them crispy green beans with that
one time pop pop sauce something that
will attract a woman learn to build
offense you know but with a gate so the
woman can come in when she sees how nice
the fence is but instead we just kill it
we just bust our pings out into the sink
or I knew--i
you know into a dirty you know an old
dirty VCR they had a guy down the street
from me and he his mom got complained at
him for you know blasting himself into
his own socks and his you know family's
different you know pieces of clothing
and stuff around the house so he he got
a VCR and he bust right into it and he
never plugged it in or anything but he
busts inside that thing like an old one
that didn't work but uh anyhow a lot of
great calls to him and we got one more
and they'll have some suggestions you
guys can offer this next listener oh
here we go here's our caller or homeward
what's up Theo my name is Jesse I'm an
Air Force ROTC cadet in college and I'm
trying to figure out this whole life
thing well all aboard Jesse and look man
you're still in college you're trying to
figure out life I like the way you're
thinking you're going to be successful
why because you're already thinking you
are thinking the world is full of a lot
of people who do not do that my friend
there's a lot of people out there and
there it's goldfish people they just
think their bowl is this big and that's
their bowl and that's it and they just
swim around in their bowl but then
there's thinkers man
and then there's thinkers in it and that
could be you
oh we're having a hard time pretty much
balancing everything and trying to
figure out what this is going in the
military is exactly what I want to do
and I wanted to do go into military
since I was younger but I'm also during
the college route and I have people in
my life that want me to come in off
services like enlisting at that nonsense
about that point in my life
I'll be 20 in a couple weeks so I'm at
that point in my life where you know
here at college is away from home you
know you learn more about yourself so
you trying to figure out everything that
you or your interests are and everything
that's different about you as you grow
as a person and I'm having a hard time
trying to figure out being an officer is
really what I want to do with the
military I'm scared that if I get out
I'm making the wrong decision the past
like five years of my life it's all I
kind of really know right now even
though obviously I haven't served them
veterans but it's just that lifestyle
that I don't know if I'm going to
struggle with if I make the wrong
decisions about quitting the program or
not so I wasn't even kind of open to
anybody if it has it has burns and I'm
finding the idea of how you could deal
with the situation but I just want to
say love the podcast keep doing what
you're doing and I hope you talk to
y'all soon
thank you for calling brother I
appreciate that
20 year old almost 20 said he's been in
Junior ROTC an ROTC man let's be
legitimate that's people chasing each
other around the school with wooden guns
after school and they had that our our
school did and they had people you know
a bunch of guys shaving their head and
um you know making hot rod cars and they
chased each other with wooden guns and
you know and rubber knives and [ __ ]
after school and stuff like that and
they were doing all kinds of and they
were doing all kinds of uh you know Lord
of the Flies type of [ __ ] where they tie
each other up outside and you know you
know do like pretend
and like eating cans of chili and [ __ ]
outside front and you know just making
fires and just ridiculous stuff I mean
amazing stuff because a lot of these
people go on to actually you know
militarize their lives but also is just
so you know it was half of those kids
that seemed like ne'er do wells that
were out there just you know giving each
other dirty buzz cuts and you know and
uh and plate you know chasing each other
around wooden guns and stuff like that
and you know grenades made out of uh you
know smoke bombs and um and cheap cement
but I don't have an answer for you man
I've never you know I had a roommate
when I'm first moved out here and his
name was Paul and we actually ended up
sleeping in the McDonald's ball pit I've
told that story before and uh and I'll
say this man he you know he wasn't sure
he was in the military and then he got
out and tried some different things then
he ended up going back in and he's led a
great path and now I think he's actually
going to medical school he's a medic and
a really smart of interest guy but and
he ended up going back he eventually
went back you know so I you know I've
been around that environment but I guess
for me what I would say is this I always
you know I've wished that I had served
you could go to it and get it done man
you there's more time than you think
when you're your age when you get to be
my age a little bit is less time than
you think but a you're aging man you
could go if you want those things you
could go get them done and be done at 24
if service and then you you know if you
feel that you owe a debt to your family
or to your country then that's out of
your system and that doesn't live inside
of you because it does live inside of
some of us men you know I think there's
all you know for me anyway for me I
can't speak for anybody else but there's
always that I asked Rick a little bit
you know or you ever fully a man if you
can't you know defend your land and uh
and and and a lot of men might disagree
with me on that and that's fine
but for me that's how it feels I'm not
saying that that's the right way to feel
but also you could ask your mother you
know you could ask your mother what she
thinks I think says she would uh you
know if you have a mother that she would
love you and she would be able to tell
you what she thinks and take her
suggestions because in the end I've
learned and I've learned it through this
show someone's called me and said all
your parents really want from you is
they want you to be happy and if they
want more than that
then it might be a little unfair but
they want you to be happy you know and
that's true man I mean all you really
are and all you really want is your kid
to be happy I don't even have any kids
but I was a kid and I'm still a kid in a
lot of ways you know and you'll always
be uncomfortable as a kid you know I
think sometimes that kid will never
leave me part of that unhappy kid will
never leave me because you always you
know you want
one that kid to be happy if he wasn't
when you're growing up you never stop
wanting him to be happy and he lives
inside of you and he's just always just
he just wants to be okay
you
and he's scared sometimes
committing to something because the last
time he committed anything was when he
was born or something you know when he
was born and when he came into existence
and he didn't feel okay then and so
really to commit to something lock his
you know to put bolts onto his story and
really it's just very scary sometimes
but those are great questions man and
we'll put that out to our listeners
sorry I'm rambling bro I'm getting a
little bit emo on this I know I'm
excited about this new set I'm also kind
of nervous I already missed the old set
a little but you mu you know it's funny
you you're so afraid to move on and then
when you finally do it's like oh okay
this is whatever this is what it was
like you know I dawdled for months about
getting that getting a this new backdrop
here in the studio I dawdled about it
for a month I don't call you know maybe
armor I put a thing on my facebook thing
6-8 months ago a year ago and then
finally just said let's do it and by
next week it'll feel like home you know
sometimes just about making a decision -
moving on moving on into it you know and
we don't we try not to be so hard on
ourselves along the way and these are
things man
I'm so glad some of you guys call
because some of this stuff I've you know
I just needed I really needed to have a
think about a think about some of these
things man holidays are coming aren't
you guys excited let everybody else
worry about that other [ __ ] people want
to argue online people want to fight
people want me to let them I go worry
about that [ __ ] ain't no Muppet like
that
you got political thoughts you take them
to the polls baby that's where you show
you a work show you work at the polls
it's uh but but sorry let's let's take a
suggestions for the young man that if
you're in the military or weren't sure
you heard his call he's not sure he's
uncertain
you know maybe letting his family down
he's been through ROTC just some nerves
on him but he's also a where you can
tell that he's aware and he's thinking
ahead of his own life and I and that's a
beautiful thing to see it's nice to know
that and that's that's awake I want to
talk about being woke dust that's a woke
boy right there
you know he's thinking about um about
what his future can look like and the
choices he's gonna make now and how
they're gonna affect him down the road
so I like hearing that but if you have
some suggestions for that young man
the number is ninety five six six four
nine five zero three give us a call we'd
really appreciate it as well you can go
to subscribe to the theological and
that's on YouTube and there's a lot of
clips on there that aren't on the main
channel and so that's something neat
that you could get involved in if you
want to see different stuff I want to
thank everyone on our patreon you guys
have been so so instrumental in in doing
some of the outreach that we're doing
and you know doing the single mom thing
doing the surprise game show for
cleaning lady thing and and I'm just
grateful and we're gonna do other things
in the future as well so I'm just
grateful that um that you guys are
around I want to thank the redditors
people that get on read in or supporting
the podcast a buddy of mine I don't know
anything about reddit you know I didn't
ask me anything on there a while back
and other than that man it's it's harder
it's a little it's you know it's kind of
like the ancient pyramids but at top
speed a little bit and so I get on there
and it's a little confusing sometimes
but somebody said the other day that
there's been a people being very
supportive on there and uh and I and I'm
grateful for that you know I'm really
excited about a guest that I have coming
in this week you know there's a podcast
called business and biceps and it's with
these guys Cory and John John Fusco Cory
G and Maurice Clarett and they're going
to be in studio Maurice is coming in
studio this week and and then Cory and
John so we're gonna Maurice him for half
and then all three of them in for the
second half and they they you know like
I get a little emo in here sometimes I
wish I was a little tougher
and one of my goals in the next year is
to kind of toughen up a little bit just
my shell you know I still want to keep
my heart in a comfortable place but I
want to start to you know I want to
start to have more confidence in myself
and I want to start to get myself a
little bit not tougher in a bad way but
just tougher where I you know where my
outside kind of can match my inside a
little bit more just more to support
myself someone have to put my chin on a
crutch and and you know Maurice Clarett
you may know his voice I mean I think
maurices voice comes from I mean you get
you're just gonna have to hear more
about his story I mean it's absolutely
unbelievable and he you know he has a
tease come from a tougher Road I think
or a more unique road to embattled a lot
of the dark arts man internal and
external and I'm just so excited about
that and I listen to them to get that
pump side of me because they're more you
know they're more they got more wolf
blood in them than I do right now but I
would like to be able to maybe you know
have a little bit more vigor and my
voice have a little bit more vinegar and
my piss sometimes but anyhow I want to
thank you guys for supporting this past
weekend thank you guys for checking out
the Bishop gun Alabama and and its sober
October and next week you know if you
have a call for the young man that was
in ROTC or you have a call a question
about sobriety or something like that
you can hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five two zero three
next week I'm gonna talk a little bit
more just about my experience I think
with sobriety and what that's been like
for me and why you know sometimes I
think I talk about stuff but I don't
know if I sometimes talk about why I
don't know [ __ ] I'm exhausted man I'll
see you guys in Appleton Wisconsin next
weekend you know be good to yourselves
make a choice don't stand there in the
middle they can get it can be
comfortable but it can be overwhelming
after a while you know you're gonna be
fine
you know take care of yourself if you're
uncertain I asked a loved one you know
sometimes you can't think for yourself
just find someone you can trust help
think for you
and you got to keep it going we may have
our you know a pass that we don't feel
great about or that makes us
uncomfortable and that can inspire us
and we can't let our stories be in vain
you know we can't let our stories be in
vain if you've been given a story and
you've been given a journey let it mean
something you know pay it off you know
pay it off because you just you've done
all the work man done all the mining you
know you something you got to look at
the gold and I say that because someone
called it beginning the podcast and said
hey man don't be so hard on yourself
you're right sometimes it's got to take
a break and a look at the gold man look
at the good things because we've all got
him you know my buddy says all the time
he says hey man we live in America you
got everything look at all the things
you he got warm foot you got food water
you got a place to sleep better than
often probably 70% of the world so we're
doing okay you guys be good to
yourselves man I hope you don't die you
know we're in Alabama
[Music]
this new studio go look at it on
youtubes boy
[Music]
she was hotter than the blacktop broke
down out of truck style she looked about
as wild as the story she said she was a
Christian saving souls in Savannah and
the Lord senator Allen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Alabama
[Music]
[Applause]
seeing the Beatles fine
she was happy I could gather around
singing right along every song on the
radio
[Music]
became a strange situation she was
Victor change the station when about a
murder
MC
[Music]
aha
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now all I want to do is make it home to
Louisiana Lord Hooper
[Applause]
[Applause]